bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 28 juin
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nous inviter
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
les titres de cette édition une nouvelle
polémique à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
cette fois ci elle concerne un projet
d'aménagement à guyancourt
le maire françois de ligne et ne
souhaite plus confié aucun projet à
l'agglomération
le secrétaire d'état à la recherche et à
l'enseignement était en visite
officielle hier dans le bâtiment
challenger le siège de bouygues
construction à guyancourt
l'occasion de voir les nouveautés en
termes de campus connectique il pourrait
se retrouver prochainement dans nos
universités et le conservatoire
international des parfums est une
institution unique au monde lost motel
situé à versailles fête ses 25 ans cette
année
notre invité patricia de nicolaï sa
précédente reviendra sur l'histoire du
site et des projets et nous vous en
parlions la semaine dernière et même
dans le journal d'hier valérie pécresse
président de la région ile de france a
changé plusieurs fois d'avis après avoir
promis pendant sa campagne qu'elle
maintiendrait le passé navigo à 70 euros
elle a finalement changé d'avis il ya
une semaine elle avait voté en l'absence
d'accord pour financer le pass à tarif
unique la possibilité d'augmenter son
tarif à 80 ou 85 euros l'augmentation a
été officialisée hier un protocole
d'accord a été signé entre l'état et
avec la région ile-de-france pour
résoudre le problème du financement du
forfait navigo après unique pour les
franciliens c'est donc une augmentation
de trois euros dès le 1er août vous
achèterez donc le passe à 73 euros qui
cela représente une hausse de 4,2 pour
cent alors est ce que vous comprenez
cette mesure c'est ce que nous avons
demandé à vous l'usagé regarder bah
écoutez je trouve que c'est dommage
parce que bahwan ils ont bien baissé
puisque effectivement ils ont fait 1
instinct tout zone quoi tout dézoner et
puis bal à nouveau augmentation c'est
quand on les prend tout le temps savez
on est mécontent à folha
si c'est pour apporter des financements
supplémentaires sûr que c'est une bonne
chose
ce que mon prix nettement quand on
compare par rapport aux autres capitales
dans le monde en europe
je sais qu'on n'est pas très cher
finalement bas cissé poté terrain en bon
état il ya pas de problème quoi jeu
franchement si c'est pour avoir la
sécurité sont en train tout ça que c'est
parfait c'est une bonne chose si ça
permet d'améliorer la qualité des
transports en commun si c'est juste une
augmentation comme ça pour faire payer
plus cher notamment les plus défavorisés
je pense que c'est complètement une
connerie et c'est une nouvelle polémique
autour d'un projet d'aménagement dans
une commune de saint quentin en yvelines
après le quartier gare à beckham de la
verrière c'est la commune de guyancourt
qui fait appel à l'état
le maire françois de ligne et ne
souhaite plus confié aucun projet
d'aménagement sur sa ville à la
communauté d'agglomération en commençant
par celui de l'ancien site de thalès un
reportage signé william l c'est ici à
guyancourt sur ces 22 hectares en friche
de l'ancien site thalès que doit voir le
jour le nouveau quartier d'habitations
proches de la future station de métro de
la ligne 10 8
problème un désaccord entre le maire de
la ville et la communauté
d'agglomération concernant son
aménagement
finalement on se demande qui préside
vraiment la communauté d'agglomération
je prenais l'image d'un avion sans
pilote ou je préfère presque celle d'un
avion qui dans la cabine verrait
plusieurs pilotes se disputent le manche
ce qui est dangereux quand on veut
définir une direction tant que la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines connaîtra de
véritables anomalies dans son
fonctionnement mais aussi dans sa
gouvernance
mais encore dans ses relations avec les
communes il n'est pas envisageable de
confier des projets d'aménagement par
exemple à guyancourt
dans ce contexte françois de ligne et
refuse de confier ce projet à saint
quentin en yvelines mais aussi tous les
autres projets d'aménagement à venir sur
sa commune
et là j'ai encore d'une posture du maire
de cuir au cou
la pseudo terrain thales depuis le début
on fonctionne ensemble et aucune
déception a été prise il n'y avait pas
de concordance dans notre vision des
choses
pour rappel que à l'unanimité il a aussi
noté que ce terrain soit racheté par
l'établissement public foncier des
villes pour le compte de l'agglomération
de saint quentin
concernant l'aménagement du site un
comité de pilotage s'est réuni ce mardi
après-midi selon le maire de guyancourt
le préfet aurait décidé à brève échéance
d'organiser une consultation d'urbanisme
et de confier la maîtrise d'ouvragé à
l'opéra de paris saclay et nous parlons
politique à présent avec un nouveau
point sur la campagne des législatives
bonsoir wilfried un bon soir flora nous
en parler mon déjà la semaine dernière
les élections législatives n'auront lieu
que les 11 et 18 juin 2017 dans un peu
moins d'un an donc et pourtant chaque
formation politique est déjà en pleine
préparation les républicains ont d'ores
et déjà investi leur candidat dans les
yvelines elia s'est pas tu représentes
peu surprise car dans les douze
circonscriptions du département de notre
département des yvelines neuf des dix
candidats sortants ont été reconduits
écoutez sophie primas elle est à
sénatrice et maire d'aubergenville c'est
aussi la secrétaire départementale des
républicains oui assez peu de surprises
en département puisqu'une des règles des
républicains c'est de renouveler tous
ceux qui le souhaitent et donc
dix parlementaires actuels veulent
continuer leur engagement au service de
leur pays et des yvelines et donc ils
ont été reconduits
tous les 10 et la voici donc cette liste
des non pas 10 mais neuf candidats
sortants qui vont briguer un nouveau
mandat l'an prochain vous le voyez du
maire de versailles dans la première aux
deux candidats aux primaires de la
droite pour la présidentielle henri
guaino et jean frédéric poisson
respectivement dans la 3ème à la 10ème
circonscription ou encore le premier
responsable du parti dans les yvelines
c'est l'ancien secrétaire d'état david
douillet dans la 12e circonscription
et puis j'ai évoqué non pas 10 mais neuf
candidats reconduit parce que arnaud
richard qui est député de la 9e
circonscription est un errant un
adhérent de l'udf il faudra donc passer
d'abord par un accord national entre les
deux parties pour qu'il puisse obtenir
le soutien des républicains
alors mes mots - se pose une question
celle du cumul des mandats et sont
plusieurs à être déjà mais en plus être
député et la loi ne le permettra a plu
l'an prochain il faudra se décider maire
ou député sauf si bien sûr un nouveau
changement de texte est opéré d'ici là
mais il n'est pas certain que les
électeurs apprécient est nu tout
simplement que le gouvernement décide de
se lancer sur ce dossier
certains vont devoir choisir mais ça
c'est leur problème et c'est leur timing
et c'est eux qui choisissent et qui
diront leur choix en fonction de leur
programme est évidemment en fonction de
leur planning à eux a pas si un candidat
actuel qui est investi pour les
législatives de l'année prochaine venait
à choisir sa ville ça remettrait
évidemment en cause
l'investiture d'une façon générale c'est
bien entendu la commission nationale
d'investiture qui devrait se reprononcer
sur l'investiture de tel ou tel
alors en attendant le party les
républicains se met à rêver d'un grand
chelem mais grand chelem dans le
département dans la région surtout le
secteur comme c'était le cas pour le
conseil départemental récemment à
l'heure actuellement 10 des 12 sièges
sont détenus par les républicains et par
lui dédie donc en 2012 les victoires
avait été plutôt net 56% dans la
première circonscription
pour françois de mazières 61% dans la
troisième pour henri guaino ou encore 54
5% pour david douillet dans la 12e
circonscription et dans les deux
circonscriptions qui ont été perdus et
bien le ps l'avait emporté avec 53% pour
françoise descamps crosnier dans la 8e
ou encore 55 30 % pour benoît hamon dans
la 11e deux victoires plutôt plutôt net
mais elle n'était pas écrasante alors
que françois hollande venait de
remporter la présidentielle et cette
fois ci le contexte sera bien différent
un mot d'ailleurs sur cette 11e
circonscription et l'élection qui prend
déjà des airs de revanche puisque jean
michel fourgous le maire d'elancourt
battu donc en 2012 a reçu le soutien et
nouvelle fois de son parti pour une
nouvelle campagne
c'est quelqu'un donc quand on connaît
les convictions assez libérale dont on
connaît le talent dont on prenait les
réussites sur sa commune et je pense que
ça sera un adversaire au sérieux pour
qu'il affrontera je ne suis pas sûr que
ce soit de nouveau penser que ce ne
serait pas lui pour l'instant au parti
socialiste on dit qu'il sera candidat
on dit qu'il sera candidat en diva qui
serait candidat dans cette
circonscription pour savoir si oui ou
non on benoît hamon sera investi il
faudra attendre encore le mois de
décembre les militants doivent se
prononcer dès que les négociations avec
les autres formations de gauche seront à
terminer et puis sachez aussi que pour
les autres partis politiques le
calendrier n'est pas encore
définitivement arrêté merci wilfried
passons maintenant à l'innovation nous
vous en parlions hier le secrétaire
d'état à l'enseignement supérieur et à
la recherche
thierry mandon était à saint quentin en
yvelines en visite officielle dans le
bâtiment challenger siège de la société
bouygues construction à guyancourt en
visitant les installations équipements
rénovés de challenger il a pu observer
les projets innovants au service de la
pédagogie de la qualité de vie dans le
campus de demain une problématique au
coeur de son plan pour améliorer les
universités et faciliter la vie
étudiants d image signée patrick jacques
de dixmude des amphithéâtres connecter
des tableaux tactiles et des cours par
visioconférence comme si vous y étiez
voici quelques innovations qui
pourraient se retrouver demain dans les
universités françaises des nouveautés
présentées à thierry mandon secrétaire
d'état à l'enseignement supérieur et à
la recherche au sein du bâtiment
challenger de bouygues construction à
guyancourt comme ce tableau digital et
tactile voilà l'idée c'est effectivement
de ça se présente comme un tableau blanc
numérique cette fois serre que on va
pouvoir écrire avec le stylo on va
pouvoir est vide effectivement avoir une
surface d'écriture assez classique sur
laquelle on va également pouvoir
interagir avec les doigts donc on va
pouvoir zoomer dézoomer et lorsqu'on va
désormais on va également s'apercevoir
qu'on appela pau cité d'avoir plusieurs
pages
cette société travaille en partenariat
avec bouygues construction sur le thème
du campus connecter une problématique
cher aux secrétaires d'état il avait
annoncé en avril dernier un plan de 50
mesures destinées à moderniser les
facultés premièrement on doit
révolutionner la façon d'apprendre la
pédagogie ça passe par le numérique est
ici dans le campus connectés dans le
savoir-faire du campus connectés de
bruit il ya ces technologies là qui sont
domestiqués deuxièmement nous avons en
termes de stratégie immobilière de faire
des locaux à la fois confortables
accueillant hospitalier nouvelle façon
d'apprendre et en même temps respectueux
de l'environnement aussi un autre défi
et je trouvais qu'il y a pas de visite
plus approprié que celle ci pour voir
des expériences concrètes de réussite de
la transformation numérique de la
pédagogie et de la transformation
durable de l'immobilier avec ses projets
de campus connectés l'entreprise
bouygues s'est rapidement positionnée
pour concevoir des espaces d'éducation
adapter le monde de l'université de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
est en pleine ébullition
en france comme partout dans le monde
car les nouvelles technologies arrivent
celle du numérique et ces technologies
vont bouleverser la vision que l'on a de
l'enseignement supérieur donc il est
important pour nous qui sommes des
intégrateurs de
lu tion de montrer comment on peut
aborder ces universités par l' usage les
mesures annoncées par thiery monde en
sont très liés à l'innovation comme le
développement de la visioconférence et
la généralisation du numérique elles
rentreront en application à partir de la
rentrée 2016 et en 2010 est tout autre
sujet à présent jusqu'au 5 juillet c'est
la période du jeûne la tradition du
ramadan pour la communauté musulmane
à cette occasion et depuis deux ans la
mosquée d'elancourt invite un soir du
ramadan des personnalités politiques à
venir rompre le jeûne avec elle est
fidèle
l'occasion d'échanger autour de l'islam
et de revenir sur les problématiques
rencontrées tout au long de l'année
les explications avec fanny bourdillon
et mélanie poker c'est ici à la mosquée
d'elancourt qu'une quarantaine de
fidèles se réunissent tous les soirs du
ramadan la rupture du jeûne
appelé aussi l'iftar se fait au coucher
du soleil suivie d'une prière
depuis deux ans la mosquée invite
également différentes personnalités
politiques à venir échanger autour de
l'islam ne voulait pas pratiquer un
islam refermé sur lui-même
l'islam fait partie de la société
française est trop de mes connaissances
ou de clichés son véhicule et est avant
tout un mode générosité de partage donc
c'est pour ça qu'on invite tout le temps
d'autres personnes aussi des personnes
d'autres confessions qui seront invités
ce soir à venir partager ce moment de
générosité de bien-être et ce jeudi ils
ont été nombreux à répondre à cette
invitation
le maire d'elancourt des représentants
de la communauté juive des officiers de
police mais aussi le député yvelinois
benoît hamon sont venus partager ce
repas dont on voit bien manger une bonne
raison et puis en plus du trou c'est une
démarche vertueuse que deux voilà de
partager ces moments et 2
euh comment on pourrait le faire avec
toutes les autres religions que ce soit
où que catholique est très au fait grand
plaisir
bien sûr il ya des règles et des valeurs
il ya ya ya ya des contraintes aussi
français vivent en france et pas
n'importe quoi c'est à des beaux pays au
monde et bien sûr il faut s'adapter
aussi à sa culture la culture française
et voilà c'est l'objet de nos
discussions régulières puissent pas se
muer en fusion est en cours et que toi
même modèle les cieux d'intégration et
de réussite
le ramadan mois sacré et quatrième
pilier de l'islam se terminera cette
année le 5 juillet et culture à présent
une exposition photos du secours
populaire sera inaugurée ce soir à la
maison de quartier du bois de l'étang à
la verrière jusqu'au 13 juillet les
habitants pourront y découvrir une
quarantaine de photos qui reviennent sur
une mission réalisée en février 2006 au
niger l'occasion pour le secours
populaire de rappeler leurs missions à
l'international comme univers où l'eau
est le premier besoin qui n'est pas
satisfait un besoin pourtant vital pour
ces populations l'exposition a donc été
nommé aman iman qui veut dire en langage
touareg l'eau c'est la vie écouter ces
précisions recueillies au micro de fanny
bourdillon c'est photo ça représente
l'aller le quotidien des habitants en
fait donc on y voit des scènes de la vie
de tous les jours pour des enfants des
adultes
et puis aussi les réalisations pour nous
avons fait la place que ça prend dans la
vie des gens donc notamment les puis il
ya aussi un retour sur des activités de
financement d'écoles que nous avions
fait à l'époque avec un c e
voilà on a essayé d'avoir un spectre
assez large et en plus en 2006 il y
avait une sécheresse relativement
importante avec des zones touchées et
donc il ya quelques photos qui relate
aussi ce que l'on a vu en termes de
malnutrition sur place alors sachez que
l'entrée est libre et si vous vous y
rendez vous pourrez également faire des
dons à l'association et acheter des
bijoux et sculptures touareg
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
entretien ce soir nous allons parler de
l'osmothèque alors l'osmothèque c'est le
conservatoire international des parfums
situé à versailles une institution
unique au monde et qui fête cette année
ses 25 ans pour nous en parler ce soir
sa présidente patricia de nicolaï on
saura vous bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors c'est une institution unique au
monde vous me disiez tout à l'heure il
n'y en a il n'ya pas sans pareil dans un
coin de pays non ça c'est franchement il
y en a pas jusque de ma connaissance
mais je pense que vraiment il n'y en a
pas c'était association a démarré il ya
25 ans par le biais de trois ou quatre
parfumeur qui ensemble se sont rendu
compte que certains grands parfums qui
avait marqué d époque beaucoup de gens
elle les avait portés par le biais de
problématiques économiques et autres
certaines sociétés disparaissent et ses
parfums ne sont plus en vente dans le
commerce
et ils se sont trouvés ils ont trouvé
que c'était très très dommage de perdre
la connaissance de ces grands parfums et
donc ils ont eu l'idée d'essayer de
retrouver les formules et de les
remonter telle qu'elle était faite au
départ pour pouvoir constituer une
collection de parfums disparu mais ce
concept a grandi et aujourd'hui nous
demandons marque de nous donner leurs
parfums actuelles qu'elles sont en train
de lancer car un parfum lancé
aujourd'hui sera sans doute un parfum
oublié demain donc le conservatoire
devient vraiment maintenant grand nous
avons plus de quatre mille parfums dans
notre collection
alors vous faites beaucoup de choses à
l'osm et equidia notamment à des
conférences qu'il ya un large public
quelle est la vocation première de ce
lieu
rassembler des parfums que tout le monde
puisse sentir
donc il ya deux axes d'activités et à la
partie collection entretien de cette
collection à la fois faire venir des
parfums nouveaux et essayer de retrouver
ce qu'on n'a toujours pas retrouvé
et d'un autre côté transmettre
transmettre c'est par le biais des
conférences et nous sommes nous
accueillons tout public
il faut évidemment réservé allez sur
notre site voir à quel moment se passer
conférence et nous en faisons plus de
100 à 150 par an ce qui est quand même
énorme car nous sommes une petite équipe
de parfumeurs ces conférences sont
données vraiment par des gens du métier
ce sont des parfumeurs créateurs
certains la retraite dont encore une
activité qui transmettent leur savoir un
grand public très large
souvent des amateurs des passionnés mais
qui découvre là des choses qui ne voit
jamais ailleurs et c'est donc formidable
nous hausse nous faisons aussi beaucoup
de formations pour des étudiants
mais la profession qui elle aussi vient
se ressourcer parfumeur marketeurs ou
évaluateurs viennent au sein de notre
association
pour avoir accès à cette histoire de la
parfumerie alors pour faire une petite
comparaison si je peux me permettre
c'est un petit peu la biblioteca
nacional des parfums mais qui est situé
à versailles
pourtant vous ne bénéficiez pas d'une si
grande notoriété comment cela s'explique
il faut du temps pour se faire connaître
il faut des moyens humains aussi nous
sommes pas une grande équipe et après il
faut des moyens financiers nous sommes
déjà très content en 25 ans d'avoir fait
tout ce parcours car comme je vous
l'expliquais nous avons démarré avec
quelques parfums une dizaine vingtaine
une centaine
et puis aujourd'hui 4000 donc nous
sommes nous avons vraiment maintenant un
statut reconnu dans la profession
nous représentons le patrimoine de cette
profession de la parfumerie
reste qu'en 25 ans vos missions ont
changé on dirait volet certainement oui
bien sûr nous allons encore plus loin
dans la recherche pour refaire ses
parfums anciens on se rend compte de
certains matières premières qui vont
disparaître ou qui ont disparu qu'il
faut absolument essayer de sauvegarder
pour refaire ses parfums ancien au plus
près de leurs formules originales sa
demande encore une fois beaucoup de
travail et d'énergie et nous venons de
passer un pataude partenariat avec
l'université saint quentin en yvelines
c'est dans le secteur de la chimie 1
il ya une section qui est en train
d'étudier la faisabilité de molécules
qui sont abandonnés par des grands
groupes
car quand une molécule n'est plus
rentable financièrement la société
évidemment ne la commercialise plus or
nous à l'osmothèque nous avons besoin de
tous ces matières premières tous ces
ingrédients qui nous servent à refaire
ses parfums anciens donc notre statut de
recherche est en train de s'élargir et
je pense qu'on va dans le bon sens alors
il ya par exemple les parfumeurs les
grands parfumeurs viennent vous voir
quand ils veulent créer un parfum vous
êtes une référence pour eux en quelque
sorte oui lorsqu'on est en fait un lieu
où ils peuvent se ressourcer ressentir
des anciens parfum essayer de resituer
un parfum dans son contexte à la fois
dans son contexte temporel mais en même
temps créatif et marc est donc en fait
on représente lorsque nous expliquons
tout ses parfums on peut déplier ce
qu'on appelle généalogie des parfums et
cela explique le process de l'évolution
de la création dans les parfums c'est
vraiment passionnant donc beaucoup de
parfumeurs évidemment souhaiterait même
avoir parfois plus de temps pour venir à
l'osmothèque mais encore une fois tout
le monde ne peut pas se précipiter
nous avons pas non plus ni là ni les
moyens ni la place d'accueillir un monde
trop trop large
alors vous le dis vous êtes une petite
association pourtant vous vous organisez
beaucoup de choses alors vous participé
notamment aux portes aux portes aux
journées du patrimoine francky lire le
public vous faites beaucoup de
conférences justement sur le sujet donc
des parfums et tout ce qui tourne autour
vous accueillez aussi un public très
large donc des professionnels des
étudiants mais aussi parfois des enfants
un peu des enfants
là aussi la demande et pour être
grandissant taux pourrait prospecter
communiquer plus largement dans la
mesure où nous n'avons pas forcément
toutes les salles pour le faire nous y
allons doucement mais aux journées du
patrimoine par exemple nous avons
beaucoup de jeunes et le la partie qui
est réservé aux jeunes et aux enfants
est en général assailli ils adorent
venir sentir et découvrir le monde des
odeurs il ya beaucoup à faire sur ce
dans ce biais la journée officielle de
votre anniversaire si je peux le dire
ainsi donc ce sera jeudi
jeudi 30 juin pour les 25 ans comment ça
va se passer il ya également deux
conférences organisées beaucoup de
choses en fait nous explique nous nous
nous recevons l'ensemble de la
profession des adhérents puisque nous
avons une association en parallèle aux
modèles qui s'appelle la société des
amis de l'osmothèque et nous recevons
évidemment nos partenaires fondateurs la
chambre de commerce qui nous auberge
dans lizzie qu'à l'école de parfumerie
nous sommes aussi la bibliothèque
olfactive de cette école mais évidemment
beaucoup de personnes faisant partie des
marques de parfums nous espérons avoir
un maximum de personnes pour qu'ils
soient plus sensibilisés aux demandes et
à l'importance de ceux de cette
association
alors vous êtes présidente donc de
l'osmothèque depuis 2008 l'aller 25 ans
il va y avoir du nouveau
est-ce que vous avez vous diriger vers
de nouvelles directions justement vrai
avenir
la profession s'organise aussi c'est un
métier qui est finalement relativement
jeune c'est un métier artistique qui
peut être complètement compris comme une
activité et qui s'inscrit dans le
culturel
donc en tant que culturel notre musée
conservatoire des parfums est très jeune
donc il nous faut du temps mais l'avenir
nous réserve sûrement de belles choses
et nous travaillons pour mieux se faire
connaître éventuellement réa se
regrouper d'autres associations de la
profession pour être plus forts et
éventuellement un jour pouvoir être plus
connus vous recherchez peut-être de
nouveaux adhérents peut-être aussi des
financements pour faire tout à fait des
financements qui peuvent venir soit des
marques soit des sociétés qui sont en
amont des marques ce qu'on appelle les
sociétés de matières premières
compositions de parfum nous cherchons
aussi du côté du culturel ministère de
la culture voire voir plus loin au
niveau de l'europe
très bien merci beaucoup patricia de
nicolaï est devenu son plateau et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions alors je
le rappelle les
25 ans de lessive cassé jeudi 30 juin si
vous voulez plus d'informations si vous
souhaitez pourquoi pas visité
l'osmothèque pardon possible que je me
suis trompé donc c'est les 25 ans de
l'osmothèque s'ils voulaient aller la
visiter voir il ya beaucoup de choses à
découvrir n'hésitez pas à vous rendre
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de votre écran vous y retrouvez
toutes les informations
merci à vous et depuis quatre ans le
château de versailles accueille le bal
de kamel ouali destinés aux adultes un
événement grandiose mais maintenant plus
seulement destinée justement aux élus ce
samedi après midi à l'orangerie se
tenait aussi la deuxième édition du bal
à des enfants princes et princesses de 6
à 12 ans étaient invités à une fête
féerique
imaginé par le chorégraphe et metteur en
scène français mélanie poquet et camille
lambert pour ce reportage
des mousquetaires des nobles des princes
et des princesses à versailles ce samedi
les enfants étaient à la fête pour la
deuxième édition d'un bal spécialement
créé pour eux c'est bien
et je suis très heureux d'être ici bas
c'est drôle parce que tu te prend relais
enfin tu fais ça avec tes amis donc
c'est encore mieux
l'association découvrir de danser et
était resté avec maître des maîtres
direction le xviie siècle mais pas de
musique baroque pour ces enfants la
musique actuelle est interprétée par la
chanteuse stade dans ce lieu prestigieux
de l'orangerie un hôte de marque à
l'origine de ce bal kamel ouali
chorégraphe de la star academy ou de
comédies musicales comme les dix
commandements
l'idée c'est de faire vivre aux gens de
notre époque
les grandes fêtes du château de
versailles à l'époque de louis xiv alors
avec les musiques actuelles avec avec
voilà avec la nouvelle technologie avec
tout ça mais j'ai quand même cette
émotion que les gens à l'époque
pouvaient pouvait vivre les enfants ce
sont le temps d'une après-midi
transformer en prince et en princesse le
faste des bals du roi soleil n'a rien
perdu de sa superbe et c'est à présent
la fin de cette édition je remercie de
nous avoir suivis restez avec nous tout
de suite vous avez rendez vous avec
nikola à kirilow vite ce pour le 7-8
société objet du débat avec et ses
invités le logement étudiant
quelles sont les solutions pour saint
quentin en yvelines
je vous retrouve demain pour une
nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite donc une excellente soirée sur
téléfilm